hello everyone I hope you're all doing
great and before I get started with this
game I would just like to turn your
attention to the quote above the board
it says any AI smart enough to pass the
Turing test is smart enough to know to
fail it it's a quote by Ian McDonald
from river of gods and when I read this
I I really got the goose bumps it's it's
you know very powerful stuff so I don't
know do you enjoy it as well or is it
just me so about this game what do I
mean by the title that alpha zero
refutes efore I know it sounds a bit
dramatic but until proven otherwise
alpha zero is the strongest chess entity
in the world that ever existed and
unfortunately we only have ten games
played between alpha 0 and stockfish it
would be better if we had more but we
don't so in the games we have alpha had
the black pieces in a couple of games
but mostly had the white pieces and in
the game that it had the black pieces
stockfish opened with e4 and alpha
immediately went for the rural opus the
Berlin defense so obviously that's
that's just one aspect of it and in all
the other games alpha played something
like d4 Knight f3 and stockfish always
ended up playing the Queen's Indian
defense which alpha really had no
problems destroying now this game is
very interesting because we'll you'll
see in the first couple of moves alpha
goes for d4 we have e six we have the
Horowitz defense Knight to c3 Knight to
f6 and now alpha plays d4 and we have b5
and what this means is that alpha
doesn't mind playing against the French
defense it only mines playing a four on
the first move because as we've seen
when stockfish has the white pieces and
when stocks which plays efore alpha goes
for the brilliant defense so although it
doesn't mind playing against the French
defense it will not play efore and reach
the franc defense through e4 but it will
reach the French defense through d4 so
I'm very interested what are your
experiences have you ever
if you're an e4 player have you ever
played against a stronger opponent or an
opponent of equal strength that plays
the Berlin and I mean of course I mean
classical time controlling tournament
chess and how did you end up playing
that game did you win or was it simply
due to hard it's okay we have the
classical variation of the French
defense d5 Knight F to D 7f for now c5
Knight to f3 knight c6 Bishop to e3
Bishop to e7 Queen to d2 a6 mushroom to
d3 and the stock fish pushes c4
we have Bishop to e2 and I don't know I
always thought that in pretty much every
variation of the French this c4 Bush
isn't really good for black Bishop to e2
we have b5 now 83 stopping before for a
while rook to b8 now castles by alpha
castles by stockfish and f5 we have a 5
preparing before now F captures on e6f
characters on e6 and now Bishop to d1
meeting before so it opens up the e2
square for the Knights of the knight can
retreat before buy stock fish
immediately a captures a captures and
Knight to e2 and here we have c3 stock
fish kind of decides he wants to
sacrifice a pawn to kind of kind of
[ __ ] White's position but you'll see
what happens we have B captures on c3
and now Knight to e6 the night to b6
sorry
and here Queen to e 1 alpha doesn't want
to capture seek after some before if C
capture some before then Knight to c4
attacking the Queen and the bishop so
the Queen can only defend it from c1 so
Queen see one night capture some before
and it seems alpha evaluated that stock
fish would have compensation for the
pawn in this position so after Knight b6
first Queen to e1 now Knight to c4
Bishop to c1 so freeing the room for the
bishop on c1 and I'll be captures on c3
Queen captures on c3 and Queen to b6
we have a king - h1 this pawn was pinned
to the king so alpha immediately on pins
nights the b2 and now either Bishop
captures or Knight will capture Bishop
on d1 either way stockfish will win the
the bishop pair and Knight to f4 now
Knight captures on d1 rough characters
on d1 and Bishop to d7
we have h4 and it's a it's an
interesting move probably probably
preventing black from pushing g5 himself
and kicking the night away from the
strong F 4 square root 2 8 we have
Bishop to d2 and now rook F to be 8 and
it seems I don't know if in in human
terms
probably the the rooks on a and B file
the Queen and b6 is compensation for the
pawn so h5 now rod captures we have rook
captures and queen to be 2 now offering
to exchange Queens alpha doesn't mind
Queen captures rook captures and we have
c3 and it seems like black has a very
active row can be 2 but in truth that
rook isn't really doing anything there
the bishop is protecting the pawn the
pawn is I mean the central pawn chain is
very strong knight on f3 is protecting
the bishop and d2 it can be dislodged so
this is probably pretty solid rock to b3
we have recreate check and rook to b8
now if the f7 then g4 and the King is
feeling a bit crowded there so after
rook to e8 check rook to b8 now rope
back to a to rook the b3 back and now g4
rook to a3 against offish wants to
exchange rooks rook to be to king f7 we
have King to g2 Bishop to c8 and Bishop
to b2 b6 now look to a 6 again offering
to exchange rooks rook to be one King to
e8
I think the g3 both starfish and alpha
are improving the position of their
kings
h6 now stopping any g5 ideas Knight to
g6 with rook to a3 back and work the b6
once again
Bishop to d7 protecting the night we
have g5 and this is a disability woman
over g5h captures a knocking - g4
preparing to capture with the night
Bishop attacks rook roped back to be -
Bishop to c8 and now Knight captures on
g5 r up to a one-night back to f3 rook
to a3 and Bishop to e1 now we have
Bishop to a5 attacking the c3 pawn twice
now and here we have rook to F 2 alpha
over stockfish to grab the c3 pawn but
stuff is declines rook to e1 if the pawn
was captured Bishop captures on c3 this
results in Bishop captures rook captures
and now Knight to h4 now the rook is
ready to jump to a fate with check King
moves then rock back to f7 check and
picks up the g7 pawn and then the H pawn
is strolling to victory probably
something like Bishop a6 Rock Cafe check
King goes back check
you grab the pawn and now this pawn is
free - free to roll so after Bishop to
e2 checking g5 you probably have to give
up this Bishop and okay you grab the d4
pawn and for a human this might be a bit
troublesome to convert into a victory
but but not for alpha and the stock fish
knows this so after rook F - row K 1
Bishop to d2 now Bishop back to the 8th
rook to h2 we have United the e7 and
Bishop to g5 here spot which plays
Knight to f5 if you were to capture on
g6 Knight captures this is again winning
after H captures Bishop captures King
captures
probably rook to f1 defending Rock to h8
check King d7 and now King protects
night and after Bishop to a6 threatening
Bishop to e2 the pin tonight came to b3
stopping that and now the White Rock is
free to grab the g7 pawn and again it's
a winning position so after Bishop to g5
Knight f5 we have Bishop character
screen captures and rook to be - now
rook the c1 and now Knight g2
h4 Knight captures Knight captures and
Bishop to d7 again you don't have time
to capture the deponents III a Bishop to
d7 comes up with a idea of Bishop we ate
and then stopping the rook from entering
f7 if you capture then rope commedia to
f2 and you can't even stop rook coming
to f7 with the King because 96 and again
you have the same thing Rock f8 checked
to f7 and then picking up the pawn so
after night h4 Bishop to d7 rook to b8
check better back to c8 and now Knight
to g2 a very interesting move here alpha
figures out that it has to give up the
c3 pawn to proceed this game you know
till victory rook captures Knight to f4
rope the c1 rook to e8 we have King to
d7 King to f3 Rock the c3 check King f2
came to e7
kingi to king f7 and now Knight to g6
King goes to e8 rook a1 rock to c7 now
King h3 Rock f7 King G for King d8
Knight to f4 we have Bishop to d7 r up
to a 7 now King to c8 came to g3 rookie
7 night to d3 now preparing to jump to
c5 king b8 now rook to a6 preparing rook
to d6 bishop to see it rook to b6 check
King c7 and now rook to d6 king b8 and
night to c5 and alpha now controls the
the entire game as black again is in
some sort of a tubes wrong it doesn't
really have a move you can't move the
rook because you lose the sex pawn you
can't move the bishop you lose the six
pawn and a move like for example King to
8 then you get a rope to d8 painting the
bishop King back and now rope the g8 and
you just have to go up the board with
the king pick up the phone with the rook
exchange works and then push the H pawn
to victory so after night to c5
stockfish now doesn't really have a move
it played g6
at age six rook to h7 and now simply
tonight captures on e6 a stockfish
captured eh pawn but now Knight to a4
with a double attack on the g6 and d5
pawns
Rock h1 Knight captures and now these
are two central passed pawns this
completely winning but again from a
completely winning position it will take
it will take 18 moves for alpha to
finish the game Rock h3 check you don't
have to suffer a couple of checks and
after after alpha finishes maneuvering
it's I mean it's a completely winning
endgame I will put a pigeon in the
description below you can if you want to
enjoy this - to pass pawns in the center
ending but it's you know purely
technical so after rook to f7 check
finally in this position
this is move 95 stockfish resigned at
the game so yeah that's the game I do
hope you enjoyed it and what do you
think is is this is what alpha tells us
if or is bad but you know playing white
against the French defense this is fine
the only thing that's not fine is going
for the French through efore so yeah
that's it I would like to thank Cameron
tab damn it worthwhile it's Erica
Roderick and Chris Campbell for a
contribution to my channel thanks a lot
- really appreciate it
as usual you can check two of my
previous videos here thank you all for
watching and I will see you soon